superman's behind bars we couldn't see  his good intentions were leading him  down a path of tyranny and evil that's  our greatest hero became our greatest  threat  Bruce consider widening your circle of  trust nobody wins all by themselves not  even you we need help don't we nut is  not that guy anymore look I get why you  don't trust me but you should trust the  Guardians this ring means something they  put me through hell to get it back don't  worry bet with this crew on the job what  could go wrong what comes next mere  mortals cannot stop we both knew when it  come to this fate will not spare you you  wish you had  all day I've been reminded how I failed  to be a hero  how many more innocent people die before  you accepted some lines need to be taken  the regime is making a comeback not  while I'm wearing this ring  this is my fight Bruce you need me  we both knew it would end this way  you